[Music]
we're out to Lille Kentucky and talk to
Emily what's up Emily hey Dr John how
are you I'm good and you I am awesome
this is a surreal moment for me I'm an
original 17 listener I can't that's so
cool so did you just like wait and wait
until like you're like oh I've got
something and then you call you know you
listen to the show over the years and
you're like I can relate to that one or
maybe I'd asked this and then I don't
know a couple weeks ago I just thought
kept thinking about this question and I
thought you know who would have some
good insight for me Dr John and let's
just see what happens and I was so
excited when Jenna called dude that's
the that's the best I'm excited when
Jenna calls she doesn't even ever call
me so that's awesome good for you it was
great it was great thank you J what's up
all right so I wrote it down so I
wouldn't get too nervous but as a long
time time listener I'm surprised I
haven't heard this question yet since I
believe it applies to others and could
help many for the backstory I was 19
when my dad developed pix disease which
is similar to an early onset Alzheimer's
but with a sudden personality change
preceding the memory loss sounds like
maybe you've heard of it yeah such a
nightmare man yeah yeah so after a
lengthy difficult Journey um he passed
away after about eight years he was only
yes yes so fast forward I'm 36 I'm
married I have a four-year-old daughter
and I can't help but ask myself every
day am i g to develop this disease do I
have 14 years left to raise my daughter
yeah yeah and so you can see like it
just gets very overwhelming and so I
know I thought maybe I get a little
upset but I know there are other people
in the same boat as me who think like
okay I'm approaching the age that my
parent passed away too young and what
can I do you know to ease that anxiety
and that fear yeah man especially when
you have your own kids just a bummer
it's way more than just a bummer I mean
you're talking I mean
you're your nervous system is still
developing when you're
19 yeah
and the the demon of PX is I mean you're
looking at somebody who's your
dad and he's looking right through you
yeah and it's it's it's and he's right
there right it's like trying to hug a
ghost you see
him right yeah 100% And I think I you
know we know at some point I think that
we're going to take care of our parents
when we get older you know because no no
no no no no no hold on hold on you hold
on you man you're good you're really
fast
um you how old are you now 30 36
36 you haven't circled
back and hugged that 19-year-old
Emily because no kid supposed to go
through
that I like to think that I have I've
done therapy over the years I know I
know you've done therapy you've talked
about it you've expressed it you've had
the grief conversations I get that so
many conversations but one of my biggest
frustrations with talk therapy often
is you're we it's all cerebral it's all
thoughts and thoughts and more thoughts
and if I just get all my thoughts in the
right order then everything's
fine
and it's still this many years later you
talk about your dad and you talk about
he's probably a pretty good guy huh yeah
he was pretty great yeah he's pretty
great and then all of a sudden he would
fumble around for the name of his baby
girl
yeah and now you have a four-year-old
and that thought becomes even more
harrowing right because you can see both
sides of the equation now when you're 19
you just experience it one way like this
is happening to me when you have your
own kid you realize what hell that
was yeah and I don't I mean I don't have
control over that but I don't want to do
that to her you know or my husband or it
just well nobody does and he didn't want
to do he didn't want to do that either
right no
um if you haven't and I know the last
thing you want to hear is I don't want
to see anybody else I want to talk about
this anymore y I get
that if you haven't gone to sit with a
trauma counselor which is different than
grief I'll recommend you doing that even
if it's two or three sessions
and probably what it will be is you
laying down like on a massage table or
you sitting down in a
chair and the counselor sitting just
behind you or right next to you and you
go back to being
19 about 3 months after you heard about
the diagnosis and then your dad wants to
goes to take you somewhere and he
forgets where he's going to take you
yeah and he looks at you with that fear
that dads aren't supposed to look at
their daughters with because dads are
supposed to have it all
together and what the counselor will do
is just simply put her hand on your
shoulder or hold your hand because your
body's got to cycle it out because it's
still holding on to
it that's number one number
two in the present I want you to not be
upset with the anxiety it's exactly
right
at 19 you experience something that
nobody should experience a hope is right
this is a gnarly hope the hope is we all
bury our parents not the other way
around right that's the way it should be
right right
and they should all be 98 and die in the
middle of the night in their sleep yes
with a smile on their face and maybe
like a middle finger to the like to the
Texas Rangers right like something like
that yeah but
not slowly dissolve in front of their
baby girl right and and so
um your body put a GPS pin in that
man and what you have to decide to do is
to feel it and to go ah there it is
trying to protect me again I'm good
now and you have that's got to be a
refrain a common always happening
refrain and you're going to have to make
sweet sweet piece with a journal and get
that crap out of your body onto the
paper cuz what your daughter's going to
feel as she gets older and older is your
chest tightening up every time you think
of that moment and then you look at
her and she's going to think that's her
fault whatever that thing that's
happening to mom right now she has to
try to solve
that and that's not her job fair no yeah
oh 100% it's not her job and I try to um
do things like leave a journal for her
and you know because there's so many
things that I think my dad would have
said to us if he could have or knew it
was coming so sometimes I think well
maybe I can quiet my alarm Bells by
writing down advice that I want her to
know like almost like have you written
your dat letter just in case you're
trying to you're trying to Seance him
don't do that he's gone yeah but he left
you right he left you he left his
amazing beautiful brilliant
daughter what you need to do on a
regular basis for a season is write him
a letter a couple of them okay and
you've heard me on the show say say it
and I always say three different ones
but you might need more cuz he needs to
know what he's missed yeah a lot Dear
Dad I would have loved if you were here
to have punched this guy out that I was
dating when I was 26 you would have
hated him how did you know that you were
like so spot on like and and hopefully
while you're writing you're laugh crying
and imagine your like the best you can
do imagine yourself at a table at a
Denning
talking to your old man yeah and don't
run from that no that would be the dream
to sit there do it but do it with a pen
and if you're a true gangster read it to
your husband out loud oh okay okay or
you GNA do something even
crazier this year let's see what you got
this year for Christmas do you have
brothers and sisters I do have an older
sister yeah okay this year you're all
going to write each other other a letter
from Dad oh okay dear
sister sure I'm so proud of
you that's a good idea you've got four
amazing kids you bathe properly now
whatever the story is right and with
whatever weird humor your dad probably
had whatever his seriousness he always
um called us by our initials even though
we're married now I don't know if he
would have changed that but if he had
have I would have gotten mad at him of
course yeah you can take whatever name
you want but for him you right yeah and
here's what we're here's what we're
doing we're teaching our
body a number one we're we're honoring a
great man yeah right who hung on the
best he could for as long as he could
that's number one number two we're
teaching our
body that we're okay
now yeah and we're going to do it in the
presence of other people which I don't
know how that works I don't know the
physiology about how that works I just
know that grief has to be expressed in
front of other people yeah and most of
us run from it and that's what the
anxiety is it's running away from that
alarm
system and so this year for Christmas or
Thanksgiving as a as a moment of
Celebration what if you ran into it yeah
walk or walk into it and you'll have one
or two of your siblings that might be
like this is insane I'm not doing this
that's fine that's fine my sister and I
so I will not give her a choice yeah she
doesn't get a choice is your is your mom
remarried she is yeah okay what if um
the three y'all three women went out and
y'all did it
together and you wrote her a letter from
your dad saying how proud you are of him
and you approve of this knuckleheaded
other guy and you're so glad that she
has you know what I'm saying yeah it
would probably be very cardic for all of
us it but very very scary because it
would be like you said unleashing a lot
of trauma over those years he was sick
yeah it's sick but but here's the thing
all of yall are feeling it yeah and all
of y'all have tried to take care of one
another by shoving it all the way down
yeah and that's
anxiety yeah absolutely and I want you
to be really gracious with Emily in the
present yeah have now there's another
part of of of anxiety that's about choos
in reality okay yeah is there any sort
and I don't know enough about this
without getting over my skis is there
any sort of MRI you can go get done to
find out if you're a candidate you can
you can have uh genetic testing done
which my husband's in the military so we
talk about maybe um going down that road
when we're retired and settled you know
I think you should go down that road
right now oh I don't I know but that Gap
that
Gap the choosing to live in the
deliberate I don't want to know that's
your body trying to get your
attention yeah right and so what we're
gonna do is we're gonna face reality is
there a teeny teeny tiny possibility if
there is I don't know the genetic
component to it it's about 50% so it's
larger I mean essentially yeah it's
scary because I'm like is it going to be
me is it going to be my sister do you
want to know do you want to know going
into those years that you may or may not
have left you can you can choose to not
want to know but you cannot get at your
body mad at your body for trying to get
your attention because it's just doing
its job true so either I'm going to
choose 15 years of anxiety and then
we're going to spin the roulette will or
I'm going to learn right now I'm going
to become one of those crazy people that
goes down every Rabbit Hole trying to
come up with any sort of thing I can do
on the front end to extend it a year 6
months five years
whatever I'm going to go to Every
clinical trial I can and I am going to
soak up every second with my daughter
yeah right and I'm going to make sure
there are video logs and journals and
whatever ever yes so that when she's
sitting down imagining herself having a
conversation with mom over over Denny's
right um she can just push play on the
video exactly you know what I'm saying
yep that's something that I think helps
to quiet my alarm Bells what's that just
knowing that there'll be more for her
like because there's more awareness it
was
very you have been like all right in 50
years I'm gonna pull my head out of the
sand I think you need to know
yeah I think I do need to know yeah I
think you need to know or just make
peace like dude I'm just I'm just
anxious that's just I'm Gonna Roll I was
gonna be super it's the same thing as
like hey how much money do you have in
your checking account like I don't even
want to know I'm just going to keep
going and uh there's 50% chance there's
money in there 50%
not your body would be failing you if it
wasn't like hey what's in the account
what's in the account what's in the
account um you got to find out what in
the account I
think I think I think it's always best
to deal with reality and then if you
find out no you're a carrier this is a
really significant chance that you've
got this we're going to grieve that and
then we're going to start making some
truthful decisions out of that um that's
just me if you were my sister or my wife
that that would be my strongest
strongest recommendation and I know it's
scary scary scary scary and so is not
knowing
to but anytime you feel that storm head
into
it and man how amazing of a legacy your
dad left
you this many years later you still miss
him so much and you still smile when you
think about
him I hope my daughter thinks of me that
way when it's my
time hang on the line Emil I'm going to
send you a copy of building an unanxious
life I want you to read through it and
use the map when your body's alarm
starts sitting off I want you to
pinpoint it on the map and we can go
from there